thomas pesquet est revenu sur terre dans
un état pitoyable incapable de tenir
debout il a terminé sur une civière en
tenant des propos totalement incohérents
ça donnait tout rose avant que les
fenêtres brûle il ya toute une équipe de
faire de sauvetage secours qui va nous
récupère moi je crois qu'ils ont été
super bon la lessive et le savons qu'il
sera habitude très très vite en fait on
est vraiment des créatures terrestres
vraiment en effet pour vivre ici donc on
a quelques heures un peu difficile puis
tout de suite on fera un petit peu nos
marques et puis on fait ce qu'on a fait
depuis les éternité géorgie d'une bonne
douche je pense premièrement avant de
faire la télé vous n'avez pas pensé
faire un peu de toilettage je parlais
pas pour les chiens
il est acteur producteur il a 52 ans et
de s'y attendait pas du tout l'américain
paul rudd vient d'être élu homme le plus
sexy de l'année par le célèbre magazine
people de la série friends à la saga ant
man il a fini par imposer son sourire
tranquille et son humour décalé pas
certain de mériter cette consécration
paul rudd a réagi je vais totalement
l'assumé je vais m'approprier ce titre
fin de citation
puis quand j'ai gardé
voilà
[Musique]
et là boum des petits moments de
la vie et du glamour j'ai les fesses qui
applaudissent en abat la moins glamour
pour le coup il est précisément six
arrêts pour ceux qui regardent rmc story
vous le voyez oui nous avons mis le même
pull céline et moi on s'aime tellement
que même sans se parler en fait on est
en connexion c'est la team rose ce matin
sur rmc story la couleur et famille il
est joli way
et montre à des vitesses les réclamer 3
raymond faure
s'est extrait
ça fait mal non je suis
la seule en cause
mais oui mimie mathy à gros trous de
balles bon au lit partout ça dans la
presse alors moi je me révolte en plus
j'étais à voir j'ai dit non t'as pas un
gros trou de balle qui
l'a très mal pris la très belle elle a
très mal pris et je lui demande pardon
mais c'est vrai que en fait c'était la
logique pure elle se vanter partout
d'avoir un très gros trou de balle on
peut dire ben en fait la taille du trou
de balle et skandar voilà c'est ça c'est
parce qu'elle est petite il paraît plus
gros voilà c'est tout ce que jeune fille
à force de se retenir de péter on peut
finir par avoir une haleine de merde
vue de répondre oui en tout cas c'est
une vraie question non je ne sais pas
lire
jamais c'est vrai j'aurais oui c'est
vrai mais oui oui le gaz peut prendre le
chemin inverse s'il voit qu'il n'ya pas
de sortie possibles de ce côté ci du
corps
[Musique]
on fera par exemple connaissance avec
les robots soignants puisque bientôt
sont des robots qui vont soigner et même
vous vacciner imaginez bien qu'une idée
pareille n'y a qu'à nice à annie ses
parts dans une piscine mbita à prades en
bas fonds de la raconter on parlera
aussi cinéma avec aline à lyne voyer qui
sied aline céline dion exactement céline
dion pour que tu m'aimes encore le film
avec valérie valérie pécresse
on va décidément on peut tolérer levé
1,6 et un menu interrogations et
spéculations sur le port du voile en
france un menu mal foutu qui vous fera
dire des choses que vous ne pensez pas
forcément
d'actualité qui divise
l'europe est devenue l'épicentre
comment remédier un peu ce qu'il veut
c'est pas sérieux ouais mais ça dépend
quoi ccc complexe s'est acheté beaucoup
beaucoup barbie kate quand même beaucoup
bill gates article beaucoup et où là où
là on est sur un dérapage complotistes à
super que c'est le financier majeur de
delaune est d'accord
ce que dit monsieur virant ne vaut rien
laissé grasset c'est factuel mais vous
vous êtes plus intelligent que
l'ensemble de la planète et face au co
vite vous avez tous dès le départ et a
préféré demander
les gens continuent de mentir et ne vous
étonnez part entière ne vous étonnez pas
que les populistes mais seuls les
populistes vont finir par parler à ce
que je sais bien c'est votre souhait
mais bon c'est pas ça comme un jour
comment il peut dire qu'ils souhaitent
[Musique]
direction l'inde à présent et regardez
ces images très surprenante alors ça
ressemble à s'y méprendre à de la neige
et pourtant c'est de la mousse toxiques
la pollution c'est de la pollution voilà
donc c'est assez grave alors cette
mousse toxiques elles recouvrent l'un
des cours d'eau sacrées de l'inde
affluent du gange le yamuna est un des
cours d'eau les plus polluées du plaisir
regardez il ya même des animaux qui
cible qui boivent la mousse
vraisemblablement été provoqué par des
rejets industriels
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
natacha polony c'est molière qu'on
assassine elle était prof de lettres en
banlieue elle a arrêté et milite contre
ce langage des cités d'ailleurs vous
disiez la langue française parfois à
trop de mots finalement beaucoup de mots
est la plus élevée je peux le dire la
même chose mais ça dépend du langage
qu'on utilise j'aimerais manger si vous
dites je suis affamé c'est beaucoup plus
fort comme en géant on va passer une
super soirée je vais tout faire pour en
tout cas pour vos petites papilles c'est
un des papilles ses voisins des papilles
pour moi pas des papiers pour moi
c'était grand père ces disques imma be
changement à genève on dit papy pour
dire grand père aujourd'hui un jeune un
lycéen utiliserait minimum un adulte
3000 m col le somme
dépasse mais qu'est ce mot que je
voulais vous êtes trop fraîche un match
plutôt sociaux et ouais si beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
regardez c'est quoi ça y est
avais tu diras cet aspect que je vais la
date c'est
une anecdote pour vous j'étais dans le
rer tranquille orge et habillée comme ça
il y avait qui mène une enquête
la voile alors tu me retourne bull
contient dans l'es19 sûrs il me dit elle
- même si c'est que nos pieds moi je
sais qu'un pied grèce
mais iphone non
non tout
le monde que vous me détestez moi il me
fait peur tout le monde que vous veniez
me fait peur